A local lawmaker is calling for a federal review of the North Oddblock project at Konell Side.
Congressman Nick Langworthy is questioning how the project's public funding changed after the developer was selected.
Our Angelica Gallagher joins us with the very latest.
Angelica.
Marley, project construction is already underway on what state the state says will transform long-time blight in the city.
But Langworthy says for him, the way this project is being funded also raises questions about the competitive bidding process before a developer was even selected.
I'm not accusing anyone of anything, but let's examine where all laws followed.
Is this project consistent with the spirit in the law as it comes to the low-income housing tax credit in the 30 million federal dollars that are being subsidized here?
The North Oddblock at Konell Side has sat vacant for decades.
Now, Penrose, the Philadelphia-based developer chosen through a state process in 2023, is building a $225 million mixed-use development with 251 apartments, 187 of them affordable housing.
But Western New York Congressman Nick Langworthy says the project's public funding changed significantly after Penrose was selected.
What caught my attention was the vast amount of subsidy that's going into creating this housing on this very sought-after piece of property.
Langworthy says initially the project was advertised as having $10 million in public funding.
Now we're looking at a staggering sum of over $600,000 per housing unit that's going to be put on this that is going to come from either federal, state, or local taxpayers.
There's an excess of $30 million just in federal monies and an additional $50-plus million in state credits as well as a 30-year payment in lieu of taxes.
It's a staggering sum of public money.
Langworthy serves on the House Committee on Oversight and Government Reform.
He believes if advertised as is now, it would have drawn a local developer to use that local funding.
In a letter to the Office of the Inspector General, he asks the U.S. Department of Housing and Urban Development, or HUD, to review whether the changes raise questions about the competitiveness of the selection process and the use of federal housing resources.
The most important thing is to investigate whether or not the material change in the bid after it was awarded and those circumstances changing is consistent with federal law to make sure that everything was on the up-and-up.
And if it is, so be it.